[Musique]
l'univers des escape game
passionne
comment expliquer cet engouement
[Musique]
un phénomène en pleine explosion en
plein développement
bon lieu de Tours un samedi matin comme
un autre nous sommes dans la société
escape time l'un des deux leaders
français de la création de ce nouveau
genre de jeu un groupe d'amis faites
l'enterrement de vie de jeune fille de
l'une d'entre elles
pour certaines c'est la première fois
[Musique]
cette saletés matiques différentes sont
proposées mais le principe de base
demeure le même 60 minutes pour s'évader
d'un espace clos en résolvant des
énigmes
les filles ont choisi l’épreuve du timer
votre émission est très simple vous
devez trouver une solution avant que les
zombies ou que le virus ne sort du
laboratoire est contamine le reste du
monde
Rémi de l'ambiance à venir
le décor est planté
on est parti 60 minutes d'immersion dans
ce laboratoire de l'horreur
bonne chance
dès lors les 5 néo laborantines doivent
relever les défis qui se présentent
chacun 10 découvert participe à la
progression de l'aventure
[Musique]
le jeu fait appel à l'observation à la
manipulation mais aussi à la réflexion
[Musique]
caché dans une pièce adjacente le maître
du jeu c'est lui qui interagit grâce à
des mécanismes lumineux sonores ou
visuels
au fur et à mesure de l'aventure je vais
appuyer sur des boutons comme juste là
en fait puisqu'on va voir le droit aux
répulsif
mais pas seulement il peut aussi
intervenir directement
j'ai surtout pouvoir quitter mon poste
30 secondes le temps de leur faire peur
cela contribue à maintenir la tension
auprès des joueuses
[Musique]
super difficile c'est le problème c'est
qu'il y a une attaque de zombie qui peut
arriver d'un moment à l'autre donc
c'est un peu flippant c'est un peu
flippant
1 2
au terme du Nord riche en émotions
mission accomplie on est sur une belle
victoire
le maître du jeu vient alors débriefer
et recueillir les sensations de chacune
on a des manières de réfléchir
différentes et on voit vraiment que on
s'entraident la copine elle pense à un
truc qu'on n'aurait jamais pensé ça
c'est vraiment marrant je pense que
toute seule j'aurais jamais réussi il y
a beaucoup de d'associations à faire
qu'on fait pas dans la vie courante du
coup intellectuellement il y a comme un
quelque chose d'amusant c'est vrai que
l'esprit groupe est toujours super
agréable et en fait c'est ce qui crée
des souvenirs aussi c'est ce moment
passant ensemble dans une atmosphère
complètement irréelle
alors justement comment est conçu un
escape game voici les deux maîtres des
lieux
il faut que ce soit mécanique purement
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que quand la
pomme tape la cible ça tombe et ça se
relève tout seul et autre chose qu'on
avait dit aussi c'est un système de
corde non avec des poulies
Gary l'ancien créateur de jeux en ligne
et Erwan ex vendeur de jeux de société
les deux hommes conjuguent leurs idées
et leurs inspirations au quotidien
c'est bonne soirée en fait on est
vraiment à deux on réfléchit on a une
petite idée ça ça germe comme ça il faut
que ce soit solide et fiable pour que
les joueurs manipulent comprennent aussi
le fonctionnement de manière intuitive
le duo s'est lancé dans l'aventure en
2015 aujourd'hui la notion de
renouvellement est essentielle pour
garder le leadership dans un secteur
très concurrentiel c'est ça la
difficulté du métier c'est toujours se
renouveler puisque on peut plus faire
les énigmes qu'on faisait il y a 5 ans 6
ans voilà les gens ont quand même fait
beaucoup d'escape game aujourd'hui ils
sont demandeurs de nouveautés donc on
essaye de proposer toujours de nouvelles
choses alors différents ressorts ça va
être effectivement soit de l'adresse
physique soit de plutôt de la réflexion
soit de la coopération et on va essayer
de mixer tout ça et de doser en fonction
de ce qu'on veut apporter comme touche à
l'énigme c'est parti vous expliquer un
petit peu comment ça marche dans la
salle
ce matin
Erwan reçoit Sam et Jeannot de Game
Master strasbourgeois ils viennent
acheter le concept super alpha World un
escape game dédié aux jeux vidéos des
années 80 développer ici en Touraine sur
Strasbourg c'est les mêmes laboratoire
on va créer les premières versions de
salle et ensuite
elles vont être donc reproduites pour le
coup super alpha War qui marche très
bien ici a été reproduit déjà c'est la
cinquième fois qui va avoir un super à
savoir qui ouvre donc la cinquième
assure Strasbourg c'est les mêmes
mécanismes c'est les mêmes systèmes les
mêmes logiciels ça c'est super
escape time possède le deuxième réseau
de France avec une cinquantaine de
salles répartie dans 15 franchises c'est
ce savoir-faire qui a attiré les deux
hommes
on a regardé un petit peu tout ce qui se
fait en France et quand on a vu la
qualité des énigmes la qualité des
décors que pouvait proposer skip time
bah on s'est dit qu'on allait rentrer en
contact avec eux en fait notre choix
était tout de suite fait on savait que
au niveau des émotions c'était ce qu'on
voulait procurer à nos joueurs coût de
l'acquisition 60 000 euros tout compris
car on est ici sur le principe du clé en
main
tu les gars nous sommes à Valère à 25 km
de Tours dans les ateliers d'escape time
Factory
on prépare au maximum un atelier ce qui
peut être fait et puis c'est des kits
qui sont livrés sur place et nos
décorateurs vont là-bas et installe
l'ensemble que ce soit l'électronique le
les mécanismes l'ensemble des meubles
sur place
la société emploi une vingtaine de
salariés pour un chiffre d'affaires
annuel d'un million d'euros
rester à la pointe de l'innovation
demeure une nécessité car on est
désormais bien loin des premières salles
de jeux forcément ça évolue en fait avec
l'ensemble du marché au début il y avait
une petite pièce de 15 mètres carrés
avec un bout de peinture de 3 meubles
chiné par ci par là aujourd'hui tout a
évolué le public forcément Satan a des
choses plus grandes et puis ça a poussé
vers le haut l'ensemble du marché
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'expérience
immersive
va être sur un ensemble d'effets wahou
comme on appelle avec des passages
secrets des effets spéciaux dans la
salle ça peut être des machines à fumer
à étincelles du feu parfois ce genre de
choses là vraiment pour que ça
voici d'ailleurs la dernière nouveauté
d'une toute autre dimension Andromède
une plongée au cœur même d'un vaisseau
spatial de 130 mètres carrés l'équipe
des skate Times y a investi 200000 euros
là je sors donc de la salle de cryostase
vous allez avoir ici la passerelle de
commandement on est dans un vaisseau
spatial donc très spacieux que jouable
jusqu'à 12 avec différents postes de
commandement plusieurs interactions avec
des logiciels et vous rentrez dans la
navette
ici présente avec le tableau de bord
plusieurs choses à configurer un jeu
vidéo qui va vous faire explorer
carrément une planète une atterrit un
moment c'est le plus du spectacle parce
que vous arrivez sur la planète
changement d'univers de décor la
forteresse royale de Chinon
là aussi la mode des escape game c'est
imposé mais sous une toute autre forme
les monuments games
alors c'est parti allons dans les Logis
Les logistes à la par là cette équipe
doit découvrir le secret des âmes
perdues des Templiers une énigme conçue
par escape time
leur terrain de jeu cette extraordinaire
monument historique dans sa totalité
s'orienter dans le château aussi fait
partie du défi en plus des énigmes à
résoudre ce qui fait que même les
joueurs chevronnés qui ont l'habitude de
faire des escape game dans des espaces
clos ils y trouvent leur compte
finalement parce que voilà il faut
s'orienter bouger
au milieu des touristes les joueurs
accèdent à des pièces des passages
secrets
dont eux seuls détiennent les clés
c'est un peu excitant et l'impression
d'être privilégié en fait donc de jouer
sans que les autres puissent voir où on
joue moi j'ai travaillé là il y a des
amis mais justement ce passage là jamais
emprunté je pense qu'ils ont dû le
restaurer peut-être il peut y avoir une
cascade
l'arme le bouclier et le monde les
Templiers ou quand la grande Histoire
s'invite à table
le monument de Game offre ici une double
dimension à la fois ludique et
culturelle sa vocation familiale permet
de répondre aux attentes du public
des écrans où on est devant la télé au
cinéma etc on est posé assis et on n'a
pas d'échange là il y a un véritable
échange qui est obligatoire entre les
joueurs il faut qu'il communique pour
réussir à résoudre les énigmes de toute
façon mais cette quête de sensation ne
s'arrête pas là aujourd'hui les escape
game se déclinent partout dans les
vignes les villes les entreprises et
même dans les EHPAD c'est parti je vous
en prie entrez dans le bureau de Jack
Weber
il est gris
j'ai l'impression que ça tombe plus vers
le bleu quand même
celui-là en réalité il est plutôt gris
car attention on ne trompe pas comme ça
nos anciens j'ai fait deux fois le tour
de monde
c'était mon truc quoi
et même à cet âge on se prend au jeu
voilà magnifique il faut arriver à mon
âge pour faire ça une première fois
chaque session nécessite
plus ou moins d'accompagnement mais on
est souvent très surpris petit à petit
on voit qu'il y a une évolution et une
progression dans la compréhension des
mécaniques de jeu la même manière touche
donc toutes les générations mais voici
l'évolution
ultime du concept la mort de repartie ou
autrement dit le cul est au géant
vous êtes venus simplement discuter en
conciliabule dans ma suite vous savez
que c'est très incorrect je m'attendais
à avoir quand même des personnes avec un
petit peu de conversation
non un château un meurtre mystérieux à
résoudre des personnages incarnés par
des comédiens et un commissaire en chef
vous avez qu'une heure l'heure est déjà
bien entamé à mon avis autour de lui 80
touristes volontaires transformés en
Hercule Poirot et Miss Marple 80
enquêteurs d'un jour transportés en 1938
on remonte parce que je sens qu'elle m'a
menti un peu cette jeune fille là
pour travailler évidemment on a des
fiches personnages qui sont très
précises parce qu'on voit respecter un
petit peu le mort s'il vous plaît c'est
très plaisant à jouer et j'espère que
les gens prennent du plaisir à nous voir
jouer
un petit moment sympa en famille le
théâtre aussi les
reconstituer le puzzle d'une histoire
celle d'un autre temps il prend le repas
pleinement c'est sans doute la clé du
succès de ses spectacles interactifs
qui plait vraiment aux gens c'est cette
liberté c'est on leur donne l'absolu
liberté d'enquêter comme ils veulent et
de poser la question qu'ils veulent
c'est ce qui nous différencie des escape
game où il y a un exercice à réussir
c'est-à-dire ouvrir cette foutue porte
ça répond à un besoin peut-être d'un
système de loisirs spectacle
un petit peu plus varié ça fait partie
de la nature humaine donc c'est pour ça
que c'est si populaire en soi
[Musique]
au bout du compte chacun de nous a
toujours adoré se raconter des histoires